-Dua, one of your biggest fans
is a man named Papa Richy.
All right?
He's 80 years old,
and he went viral on TikTok
after his granddaughter
surprised him with tickets to
your concert for his birthday.
His reaction got over
7 million views.
This is real.
Check this out.
-"Admission ticket,
Richard L. Waldorf."
-"And Elena Waldorf."
-"Dua Lipa in concert"?!
Are you [bleep] me?!
[ Laughter ]
Really?!
Is this a real thing?
-Yeah!
-Holy [bleep]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, it's just
such a good video.
-Yeah.
-It made me so happy.
-Well, since he's such
a huge fan of yours,
we wanted to give Papa Richy
another surprise.
And this is real.
It's happening right now, guys.
We reached out to him,
pretending that we were
a radio station, okay?
In New York, and told him
that he won a contest
for the number-one
TikTok video of the year.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Amazing.
-He believed us.
He loved it, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, yesterday, we flew him and
his granddaughter to New York.
He's in our building right now
as we're talking.
The TV monitors are not on
in the building.
And he thinks he's about to be
interviewed on a radio show
and get a tour of 30 Rock.
And here he is
a few minutes ago.
We have GoPro cameras.
That's his --
[ Laughter ]
So he has no clue
what's going down.
And, in fact, someone --
There was some
"Tonight Show" sign,
and he said,
"Oh, I love "The Tonight Show.'"
[ Laughter ]
So I was like, "Oh, cool.
This is gonna be great."
-Well, he's gonna --
he's gonna get the surprise...
-Of his life.
-...of his life.
-All right, so right now,
we all need to be really quiet,
'cause, seriously,
he's being led to what he thinks
is the radio station.
And what he doesn't know is,
he's about to walk
onto "The Tonight Show"
and meet Dua Lipa.
[ Laughter ]
All right?
So, all right, let's get ready.
He's --
-Should I come with you?
-Yeah, you come with me.
We'll hear it.
We'll hear it when he's here.
-Ready as
we're ever gonna be.
-Your first radio interview?
-First radio interview.
-Oh, great, good.
-Papa, I will follow you.
-Okay.
I'm gonna follow.
-He's coming through.
I think we can hear him.
[ Laughs ]
-Well, I'll follow you, Pop.
-Okay.
-Okay? You first.
-I'm a real Jimmy Fallon fan.
-This is where Jimmy
always gets ready over here.
-Oh, my God!
Hi, Jim.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll just cut through, uh...
-Everyone,
please welcome Papa Richy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Jimmy Fallon.
-Thank you.
-I'm Jimmy Fallon.
You're on "The Tonight Show."
This is Dua Lipa.
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Holy [bleep]!
-Hi!
-Oh, my God!
Can I -- Can I shake your hand
or something?
-Of course.
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Hello.
-Your hands are freezing.
-My hands actually are freezing.
-And this is your --
This is your granddaughter?
-Yes, I'm Katie.
-Katie, how are you?
Jimmy.
-Hi, Katie.
-It's Katie's 22nd birthday.
-It's Katie's birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
-Happy birthday.
-What a present
this is right here.
-Yes.
-Now, I read something that said
that one of your dreams
is to dance with Dua Lipa.
-Yes, yes, of course.
[ Laughter ]
-Can we make --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Can we make that dream
a reality?
Oh, my --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
Ooh!
All right, let's --
-You're supposed to be --
You're supposed to be on tour.
-My thanks to Dua Lipa!
-I am on tour.
-Papa Richy!
His granddaughter Katie!
Happy birthday!
Stick around!
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show" after the break.
♪♪
-We were at your first show.
-Oh, you were?
-In Miami.
-In Miami?
-Yes.
-Did you enjoy it?
-Loved it.
-I'm so happy.
-That first outfit you had on --
that green outfit.
-All right, all right,
come on, now.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, all right.
♪♪
-I got to dance with Dua!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! Oh!
-Get out of here!
Get -- wait.
-Ohh!
-Be careful.
-Amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]